voici vous rejoins verdi
bonsoir bonsoir
tous très heureux nous avons avec nous
alors qu'on s'interdit double actu donc
d'abord un livre qui s'appelle les
rythmes du zodiaque
c'est au cherche midi
voilà ça c'est pour le team a pu aussi
indice c'est un best-of qui s'appelle
message personnel c'est chez virgin
celle ci aurait commencé par le disque
donc c'est une compilation mais qui a
une particularité c'est que les morceaux
ont été choisis par vous pour une fois
l'habitude c'est les patrons des maisons
de disques qui font ça sans vous en
parlait sans vous en parler voilà oui
donc j'ai choisi des chansons qui ne
sont pas tellement connu du public qui à
mon avis sont aussi bonne sinon meilleur
que des gros tubes donc genre il ya des
gros tubes genre comment te dire adieu
partir quand même si jamais entendu ça
comment te dire adieu je ne sais pas
c'est le simplement vers moi partir
quand même le rang j'y vais deux minutes
que peut-être françoise hardy ça me
revient par bribes voulait que je ne
vous oublierai jamais et puis alors il
ya des chansons moins connues
effectivement comme le crabe
tu connais le crâne dans le crachin
nîmes à cela des chansons qui ont fait
que françoise hardy d'une icône culte
chez les jeunes musiciens chez jeune
chanteur a commencé par etienne daho
blur aussi tu sais que les mecs de blur
sont fans de de françoise merville je me
suis mis seulement si jeune que ça deale
prix de charlie free tout le monde adore
franchement c'est ça c'est de partir un
jour groupe
le beau-père si vous êtes d'horaires oui
j'ai d'ailleurs enregistré une chanson
avec eux voilà c'est dingue à 7 juin
marianne faithfull de france est
vraiment mieux non plus je n'ai pas dit
mieux en plus maintenant qu'un jeu